hey youtubers is Charlie so how much
awesome news HBO is the TCA is this past
week they teased a whole bunch of really
cool stuff that's coming down the road
there are more episodes coming than we
originally thought which is awesome
there's also news on the spin-off that
they are now very definitely doing so if
a new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway starts now it's for one of the
enhanced editions of the books all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
winners are usually announced at the end
of videos if there's a round this ending
be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
so a whole bunch of news all of it is
really good it's like the stuff that you
want to hear that make you feel a little
bit better even though Game of Thrones
is like slowly coming doing it so number
5 the HBO people were presenting all
their new series for this year to the
Television Critics this past week they
always get a ton of Game of Thrones
questions even though they didn't bring
any Game of Thrones stuff they've
revealed that the show has not been
formally renewed for season 8 just
because they're still going back and
forth on what the final episode count is
going to be meaning we could get more
episodes next year for season 8 right
now this year season 7 is capped at 7
episodes it sounds like a bummer but
each of the episodes is going to be
longer crazier in looking back at the
previous seasons I don't really think of
any of the older episodes is filler but
more money and more action going into
fewer episodes sounds like a good thing
right now season 8 is supposed to be six
episodes so when they say there could be
more episodes that could turn into seven
it could turn into eight there's just
like a set number of hours that Dan and
Dave wanted to tell and it's probably
going to be a while before they decide
because they don't start filming again
till way later this year they'll
probably have some more news about that
when we get to comic-con number 4 the
money is also a big reason for fewer
episodes but HBO is happy to spend it
each new season it gets more and more
expensive to do Game of Thrones because
they're doing bigger battles they're
doing more dragons so just for example
this is totally nuts just to break down
some of the finances on Game of Thrones
during season 6 the episodes cost an
average of about 10 mil
in dollars per episode that's about a
hundred million dollars for the season
the Battle of the bastards episode was
way more than that so just for example a
normal episode of an hour-long drama on
a big network like a really big show is
closer to like three or four million
dollars per episode on a smaller cable
network it's way less than that so HBO
is just like shoveling money out to do
episodes of Game of Thrones they're
totally happy to spend as much as it
takes to make it as crazy as possible
but there's a limit to that like they
just can't spend two hundred two hundred
fifty million dollars on a single season
of TV they don't get that much money
from subscribers that's where HBO's
money comes from they don't sell ads on
their stuff they get money when people
subscribe to HBO's channel so number
three that's where you get to the
spin-off one way to keep those costs
under control is to start a spin-off
where you get to wipe the slate clean
bring it a bunch of new actors that
don't cost as much and you can do a
really awesome story at a vastly smaller
price point so this past week in the
same breath when they were talking about
doing more episodes during season eight
they were also asked about the spin-off
they get asked about spin-offs every
year and they typically say the same
thing you know maybe we're thinking
about it we're probably going to do a
spin-off this year though they said that
they would be stupid to not do a spinoff
so if you're starting to worry that
there might be a time when there is no
Game of Thrones on television that's
probably not going to happen it will be
a prequel but they haven't decided on
what that's going to be George our
Martin is still finishing winds of
winter which he says is going to be done
this year we'll talk about that
eventually - but he's been pointing them
to all the best stuff to do for a
spin-off remember a spin-off would have
to go for about seven seasons so it just
depends on what kind of material they
want to mind in how much action they
want it to be what kind of series they
want it to be so the big three picks
right now are tales of Dunkin egg
Aegon's conquest in the dance of the
Dragons if you haven't read the books
I've already done videos about what
these stories are so add some links at
the end of this video but HBO in Gen
roll sounds like it wants to keep the
Game of Thrones creative team like the
producers the people that write it the
people that actually make it like the
actual people that work on it day to day
together for whatever the spin-off is
going to be but last year Dan and Dave
said that the main series might be the
end of their day-to-day involvement so
even if they do bring a new showrunner
it sounds like Dan and Dave would still
stay on as producers the basic takeaway
is that the people to give you Game of
Thrones would essentially be the same
people that would give you a spinoff
it's just behind the scenes some things
would get shuffled around a little and
even though he's still finishing A Song
of Ice and Fire
George R Martin would probably increase
his role especially at the initial
stages just to make sure that everything
started off on the right foot so if you
came late to Game of Thrones what
happened early on is is that george RR
martin was heavily involved with the
first couple of seasons he wrote
episodes each season but then as things
got on later he started to get pulled
away by the book series trying to finish
that so right now he isn't as involved
with Game of Thrones on television as he
used to be that would probably change
with the spinoff in a couple years so
number two what about the stories so I
listed the three big picks but it really
just depends on how much easier it gets
to do the cg dragons and really like any
of the other CG elements that they
include usually special effects get
better and cheaper each year so if you
go all the way back to season one and
watch Daenerys hatch her dragon the CG
looks okay it still holds up relatively
well but it was still kind of expensive
at the time today just a few years later
it's way easier way cheaper to do that
but today they're doing really big
dragon so they're still really expensive
but what they're doing today will be
cheaper tomorrow that's the big takeaway
so it's not going to be hard to do CG
dragons in a couple years so dance the
Dragons or Aegon's conquest would be the
most WTF action-packed stories for them
to adapt Aegon's conquest would be a
little cheaper just because there are
only three dragons instead of a bunch of
people fighting each other on dragon
back I can't even imagine how expensive
it would be to do regular
dragonrider battles it will be the best
thing ever but it would probably crush
HBO's budget so on the other side of
that tales of Dunkin egg would be the
cheapest because there are no dragons
there just like a bunch of big crowd
shots there are a lot of attorneys a lot
of regular fighting on horseback is a
really fun story it's kind of like a
buddy roadtrip story it's not really a
comedy but there is a lot of comedy
imagine Brienne and Podrick riding
around that's kind of what tales of
Dunkin egg would be like hollers forgot
I'm okay
I don't need a [ __ ] kosher dude so it's
a really fun story
George R Martin said that he's writing
more for those characters in the future
too but it doesn't really have big lead
wedding level WTF twists like Aegon's
conquest or a dance of the Dragons most
of you guys seem like you would rather
see dance of the Dragons than Aegon's
conquest just because a lot of what
Daenerys is doing in these final seasons
is very similar to what Aegon the
conquerer did so it kind of be like
doing the same story if they went back
and did the conquest but the dance of
the Dragons has all the really crazy
stuff but it's about a very different
event with very different groups of
characters but again all really solid
pigs what would probably happen is is
that they wouldn't actually settle on
what the spin-off is going to be until
after the final season of Game of
Thrones
they'll probably focus all their energy
on marketing season 8 next year and then
as we get towards the end of that
they'll announce what the next spin-off
is going to be develop that and then
there might be like a year or two before
they premiere that so if the main series
goes off the air in 2018 that means it
might be 2020 before we see the premiere
of the spit off but number one when are
we actually going to get new footage of
season seven we got a little teaser at
the end of last year which is sort of in
keeping with their style like they have
like really small stuff that they'll
drop in December then in January the
first trailer usually drops but because
when they were filming season six it was
like their normal filming schedule they
had finished filming most of the
episodes by the end of 2015 so they had
all the footage they needed to cut
trailers this pasture was different
because winter has come to Westeros so
they had to wait till later in the year
to start filming meaning that they're a
couple months behind so if the first
real trailer usually dropped in January
that means we might not get the first
season 7 trailer until February or March
because there's such a big delay this
year like season 7 might not premiere
till late in June they'll probably try
to do some extra cool stuff just to keep
the fans happy market the series and
just keep everybody calm down till the
premiere so as of right now they're
still filming episodes but they filmed
most of the series they have as much
footage as they need to cut a trailer so
it will probably be a little while but
they have a new series called the young
Pope's it's premiering later this month
they might use that to promote some Game
of Thrones stuff so we might get some
more Game of Thrones teasers while that
series is on the air but as for the
actual footage last year was all about
teasing Jon Snow's return Daenerys
breaking the wheel of slavers Bay this
year is all about Daenerys conquest in
the war for the dawn so expect whatever
teasers they drop to hype up Daenerys
versus Cersei in Jon Snow versus the
night's king so everyone's converging
before a big season-long battle with the
White Walkers next year so this is all
about the characters coming together
clashing sort of like a war of the five
kings only now it's much more
centralized so I'll still be doing
weekly bonus videos until the season
gets here if you want to leave requests
for my next game of Thrones video just
put it in the comment I'll say
congratulations to this week's Game of
Thrones giveaway winner pair Lord you
win a copy of one of the enhanced
editions of the book please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round of this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
the Game of Thrones video new Sherlock
finale posting tonight then a whole
bunch of comic book stuff posting on
Monday what you guys wait for that the
post you can click here for that dance
of the Dragons video and you can click
here for the Aegon the conquerer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
five I'll see you guys tonight
you